[Music]
hello hey guys we're here at Lake
Thompson's house we're supposed to shoot
this video about saving money on your
electric bill but it doesn't look like
he's home but we're not about to pack up
waste all that gas and drive back out
here later we're gonna conserve that
energy and do this thing anyway guess
you don't need to lock your doors around
here and you know what they say when the
cat's away the mice will play let's do
this
turning your thermostat down 10 or 15
degrees for eight hours a day would
shave 15% off your bill smart
thermostats make it easy to set it and
forget it your water heater is probably
set way higher than it needs to be turn
that bad boy down to 120 degrees and
watch that bill drop lighting takes up
25% of your energy bill but LED bulbs
use 90 percent less energy and last up
to 25 times longer replace five bulbs
and you could save up to 75 bucks each
move up to 90 percent of your washing
machines energy goes to heating the
water skip the hot cycle and wash
everything on cold with a cold water -
Turkey
your refrigerator is the only appliance
in the house that runs 24/7 save money
by keeping the fridge temp between 36 to
38 in the freezer between 0 and 5 even
when your electronics are turned off
they're using phantom energy which can
amount to 15% of your bill clock all
those gadgets and the power strips for
one tab shut off like a bottle George
what are you doing here and there's your
minute money hack get out if you enjoyed
this video we've got a whole minute
money hack playlist waiting for you
right here on our YouTube channel and if
you've got some energy saving tips we
want to hear them leave them in the
comments below